do you know that throughout the year you
spend the equivalent of more than one
entire day on the toilet but what if
instead of spreading that time
throughout the whole year you just got
it over with in one single day what if
you only went to the bathroom once a
year
how much poop does a person produce in a
year what would sitting on the toilet
for this long do to your butt and how
would your colon handle something like
this this is what if and here's what
would happen if you pooped once a year
it's been reported that some people have
withheld going to the washroom for up to
one month
refraining from going this long can
result in some severe health issues some
have even had surgery because of it but
what if instead of a measly 30 days you
held in your poop for 365 before we get
started on this journey we should
deconstruct exactly how much humans go
to the bathroom throughout your life
you'll spend nearly ninety two days on
the toilet that's right over the course
of a week you might spend anywhere from
90 minutes to almost two hours doing
your business but within that time how
much feces might you be evacuating well
by the time you reach age 65 the average
person will have pooped over nine and a
half thousand kilograms of feces that's
about the same way as three trucks
combined so if we're only letting you do
this once a year you would produce 146
kilograms of feces that's more than an
adult panda weighs now that we know how
much poop we're going to get rid of what
will sitting on the toilet for 24 hours
do to your body but first if we're gonna
sit here this long what would you do
well you could read a good book but in
24 hours you might not be able to finish
it
with this episode sponsor bling Castilla
could read over 100 books by the time
you're done here
blink Asst is a service that condenses
the best parts of nonfiction books into
just 15 minutes for you to read or
listen to I know with all the
distractions today it can be hard to sit
down and read for a couple of hours I
mean who has time for that anyway but
with blankets we here at what if have
been able to learn a ton of new things
in a really short amount of time we
obviously really like the science
section a book I recently read and I
think you guys will like is titled
physics of the future it talks about
what future technology will look like
according to top scientists the first
100 people to go to blink is calm / what
if we'll get unlimited access for one
week to try blankets and if you want the
full membership you'll also get 25% off
so go ahead go on over guys and sign up
it helps the channel out and there's no
risk you can cancel at any time now
let's get back to the video what would
happen if you sat on the toilet for 24
hours straight
well you'll quickly notice that your
legs and feet will fall asleep sitting
in this position can put pressure on
your nerves and cut off your circulation
so your legs will feel tingly and numb
usually when this happens you get up and
walk around and you feel fine within a
couple of minutes but in your case
you're going to be here for a lot longer
and sitting this long can cause blood
clots these are clumps of blood that can
form due to immobilization at times
these can move around your body and get
into your heart or lungs and stop your
blood from flowing or prevent you from
breathing but just sitting there will be
the least of your worries that's because
during these 24 hours you'll be going to
the washroom for the entire time and
you'll be forcing 146 kilograms of feces
out of your body most people don't even
weigh that much so doing this to your
body would put a ridiculous amount of
strain on your colon and
but you'd get hemorrhoids and it's
likely that your colon would rupture and
could even burst whether your colon
ruptures or bursts feces will then seep
into your abdomen
now all that bacteria that was meant to
stay in your colon is loose in your
abdomen this would cause a severe
infection and maybe even kill you if you
could manage to have a colon made out of
reinforced steel you could potentially
survive this sure your butt would be
sore and you might risk getting a blood
clot but the chances of these things
being fatal are to guarantee but you
should also keep in mind that having all
these feces inside of you you'll be
lugging around 146 kilograms of extra
weight gaining this much weight over the
course of one year would cause some
serious issues in your body throughout
the year you'll move slower and slower
your stomach would keep expanding be
bigger than ever and on top of all this
you'd be dealing with severe chronic
pain so although sitting on a toilet
once a year might feel like a way to
save time there's just no way your body
would be able to handle this what if
instead of sitting on a toilet we sat in
a bathtub for up to one week well we'll
save that story for another what if
you
[Music]